for alex this must feel like the perfect
storm
heavy snow no water no electricity
and a baby due now i think she's
maybe instinctively kind of holding back
on having the baby just so
we can maybe have power and water and
roads can be a little bit clearer to
to get out but yeah definitely
definitely unnerving as we've gotten
closer to the due date his family has
stocked up on
food and supplies the habits of the past
12 months
now reaping a dividend it's a lot kind
of like what we've just gone through
with with the
pandemic um you know you're you're kind
of without services
you're without places to go so to a
certain extent we're we're a little used
to it
um you know we've stocked up in the past
for for water and
paper towels and frozen food items and
those type of things so
this this storm is kind of a little bit
of a continuation of the same thing
but across texas there are now signs of
real stress
delivery lorries can't get through
supermarket shelves
are emptying and still there are people
in this the richest country in the world
facing sudden brutal hardship we're
nervous
because people are starting to lose
power again you know right now i'm just
worried about
does my son have enough food you know i
mean
kind of so i mean i've been trying to
find stuff but
it's gotten hard another snowstorm made
the roads even more icy and treacherous
this state has precious little
experience of arctic conditions and it
is struggling to cope
well this community has had a series of
power cuts which is why they've
hired their own generators to help them
cope they've also been without
water for a couple of days and even
when it comes back on we've just seen a
pipe bursting now
it is hard to prepare for a once in a
generation event like this but there is
also
anger that more wasn't done to plan
ahead
and also that when they look at downtown
dallas
the banking headquarters and skyscrapers
simply don't seem to be affected
by the problems that they're having to
deal with here it is that stark
difference
the feeling that the rich elite are
somehow insulated from pain
that infuriates many obviously they're
going to have electricity down there
because of hospitals that's smart
you know we have to you know that's
where they need it the most i get that
but
you know those big companies and all
their big lights that's just
screams you know i don't give a crap is
what that screams
i just couldn't believe this happened
they should have been way more prepared
for this you know
i've seen where there was situation
before and
they knew that they should be prepared
for having you know the electrical
power to supply all these houses during
a tragedy like this
texas has had days to sort this out but
still it is in a state of chaos
there's warmer weather on the way for
many here it can't come soon enough
adam parsons sky news avondale